not cursing and made C you're asking two
British people and an Australian to not
curse why do this have to go to the
tallest member this guy like s out
online remember that I will bribe you
you don't want me to call the manager
[Music]
man
hello and welcome to another episode of
trash taste outside guys special yay
Conor what are we doing today we have
been tased with being the most kaai maid
that we can but unfortunately we're not
doing it in Japan we're doing it in
Australia the most made friendly place
of all not only are we doing it in
Australia but we will be serving our
fans who attended dream hack Melbourne
2023 and uh there was a lot of people
and we were very embarrassed but before
we started serving real customers we had
to learn how to be the most Kawaii Maids
possible so that's what we did maid
cafes one of the Staples of weeb culture
as the world's leading anime podcast we
knew all about maid cafes except how to
be a maid ourselves with our goals set
in mind the first thing on our list to
becoming the best Maids possible was to
learn from the pros themselves heading
to the weeb central of Tokyo we made our
way to akih Habra to visit a maid Cafe
and thankfully we had some help that's
right we had reached out to someone who
has their fair share of made experiences
and that was shib yaho time to see what
we're getting ourselves into now I guess
I didn't know you were working here all
of a
sudden what job don't you work is the
question I I'm regular out anywhere
pretty much so what are we doing today K
are you teaching us how to become
Amazing Maids mhm mhm like a legit maid
we need to acquire those skills right we
need no cursing okay no cursing at made
Cafe you're asking two British people
and an Australian to not curse that's
hard I have one question how do I become
more Kawaii I just I'm I'm kind of
struggling my daily life the dude with
the deepest voice how do I
become how do I become more when I'm
this Jack just a smile you let's let's
let's see your smile Corner
yeah oh wow look at that
menu That's So Cute I'll get the magic
Shaker can you pronounce it that's the
name of that drink it's Miku juu Ju juu
it says juu yeah like a baby word not
just juice like ju I I thought it was
like a ju juy K of course I picked the
baby one oh my
God I ain't being the baby man
allegations man what what can I say I
might go for one of the C The Latte I
might do
the hot hot Machel I think I'll go for
the tea one of the tea cups look really
nice I'll go for oh caram tea caram tea
I St so you know I'm still not confident
as a ma okay I I need my Senpai to
notice me and then Senpai is going to
give you like an entire M experience
that sounds great I love
that oh hi oh
hi but before we could begin we had to
get our very own Ma Master cards oh we
got to membership card certificated
master
H Gold
Card the anime man
Master finally a master fate fans I did
it like how this says non-transferable
so you can't level up with your Bros you
can't be like giving your card out to
your boys if they want to go you can't
gain the system can we use this card at
any establishments can we use it at uh I
saying you go to the airport lounge be
like oh you got access yeah I'm part of
the I think they turn you away from
here
hi okay okay will I feel the mo power if
I take a sip of this let's see cheers
everyone Che Cheers Cheers boys smells
like MO
oh I can feel it
oh we've reached a level Beyond Voss
water but now let's all the things yeah
let's food of course I've got to have
it's not just a hamburgo it's a well
it's a cute puppy Curry hamburgo
car not just car rice car Raichu ra of
course you pick the one again that
sounds like a
[Laughter]
baby
kind of realized uh being in a maid Cafe
I think triggers my fight fight flight
response makes me want to stand up I I
had energy when I turned up today and
the more energy that is is over here I'm
like oh oh I'm losing my energy you know
when you hang out with someone who's
like way too extroverted for like too
long this is what this is like I'm just
getting
tired why do we have 50 strong I know
you can choose a Conor the turtles are
crying why that why is there a I order
that I order I made C well you know I
mean I sort of spice it up a little bit
it's it's 11:00 I thought we were eating
lunch we're learning how to be made this
is not a very ma like right now sorry I
thought this was a host club for a
second
with us
yeah start I I need I need to
emotionally prepare myself it's a drink
bro come on you don't understand I don't
do this with my beer I'm just going to
bring it we'll keep rhythm for you it's
okay 3 two 1
[__] Shaka Shaka Shaka
Shaka this
y
long I'm looking at a producer just
right behind the camera and he just
like which color do you like I got to
get the pink color
to oh that's so cute kind of
cute wait wait wait I I get I get a 12
step Chan and and there's like okay
here's your tea no worries no worries I
went for the British combo a beer and a
tea oh hell
yeah
not we step we need to
do let's make a
heart yeah this is Tech you have to have
a proper form charging up the okay
learning from the professionals
here
[Music]
it's like an unskipable cut scene for my
drink let me let me skip it let
me
do you have any advice on how to keep
customers
[Music]
happy
big
boys G the hand gesture not just
hard so just take all of your
personalities and just crank it up to
like level 11 that's that's that's what
I've heard what I'm saying is uh anime
Zone hand gestures all right yeah you're
going to have to like start doing this
[__]
like I think you might need this after
that this might he might
I think you might I think
you okay so a few things I've learned so
far from this experience okay one it's
all about adding some kind of
performance to every item in the menu
whether it's something you know simple
like Mo or we can even put our own spin
to it
yeah thanks for your input I'm about to
say something yeah I I was and then I
realized I'm still like emotionally
recovering from uh what I just
experienced thank you so much for
teaching us everything about being a ma
I think we've all learned that MOA is
the crucial important part of being a
ma your energy was very infectious and
hopefully we can take some of your
energy and uh take it in ourselves and
show it off to the customers thank you
with everything we'd learned so far we
were ready for the real thing in
Australia but let's just say the outfits
we got may not have been the perfect fit
it's a 5 XL this just not a 5 XL boys
there's also if anyone wants to fight
for it a pink one oh my God
one keep going until one person
loses t wait what goes first y Jo what
is that going to cover is this going to
fit me you're going to get arrested Joey
for incent exposure the 5xl that's the
5xl that's actually pretty oh oh that's
not going to cover me oh oh sh I'm going
to get Chang to the toilet and
I'm right play huh all right what's up
welcome back to the trash main Cafe look
at this fit look just go like this the
one good thing about these outfits is it
is really easy to [__] in
them you just having trouble yeah we all
are don't
worry your like too big it's actually
too put the other one you can put the
back on you look like one of those
hookers you see at like 6 a.m little
better this fits a little bit better I
didn't realize I was this small in
stature it's been a while since I've
done this but there something there
something you just don't forget it's
like right in the bik I'm so glad I'm
not doing this by myself I I feel like
I'm doing something El I'm definitely
doing something I'm going to have my
first cigarette
break what do you
want we don't got it oh I think I got it
I think I got it you have to like put it
on oh like it's an apron that's what it
is that's exactly what it is we figured
out the secret help me out
here oh there we
go master I'm ready for your a on cavity
search hey about to St I'm gaming right
now I'm playing Omega Strikers this
video is not sponsored by Omega Strikers
you guys are just taking 10 years dude I
had a
game welcome back to the trash t m Cafe
may I take your order
actually jokes on you you can Chun on
these
nuts well we are ready to serve our
masters ladies are you
ready no Joey ladies are you ready Joey
I'm sorry I'm I'm the new M today I'm
the new M I'm sorry I don't know what
I'm doing you better do a good job
that's what I want from you well let's
go the customers are waiting it's time
to serve oh my
god with our questionable outfits on we
made our way out to the cafe and of
course our lovely customers were already
waiting for us oh God it was now time
for us to use everything we learned and
proved who the best made in trash taste
was my plan is a simple one I need to
find out when they tip and then I will
simply bribe them ladies first there you
go thank you uh Jens you can sit down
yourself that's all right you can film
me but here's the deal you have to vote
for me okay of course what table number
do you want you you got favorite number
what's your favorite number number we
don't have 69 my is yes yeah but am I am
I the cutest one
here okay well the correct answer is yes
first of all the ears are really selling
it for me the ears yeah yeah right who's
going to vote for me for the best made
all right I'll serve all of you guys all
right come on go to that table right
over there come on through come on
through what do you guys what should I
call you guys uh Team Conor team Conor
yes all right I'm going to put you next
to the other team Connor all right guys
we got one more table for now is it the
three of you all right come on in guys
Connor I've taken I've taken the last
table Connor this guy's going to stand
next to you while you guys eat is that
okay stand right here wait do you have
no ketchup I don't know have to ask you
I'll go get you some ketchup hold on a
second all right I can't I can't allow
that that's disgusting does anyone else
need ketchup anyone need ketchup all
right but you have to vote for me I'm
going to get a bunch all right all right
do you guys need anything by the way no
you sure you don't need ketchup mustard
or anything you want some Stu yeah yeah
yeah yeah all right got you I've got a
very very important question for you
guys are you bone in or boneless
boneless bone B my good sir is there
anything you want do you want uh do you
want ketchup do you want uh do you want
do you want a do you want a free drink
or something like that yeah ketchup
please ketchup all right all right all
right [__] you guys where's the ketchup
no no I'm already wait that's like a
bunch
there can I just take the bot oh my God
he just stole my idea all right who
wants ketchup I got ketchup keep your
hand up up if you want ketchup there you
go there you go take it take it there
you go there you go thank you no I've
already done it I've already done it g
what are you doing I'm getting one
ketchup all right did he just take my
catchup what do mes do when the seats
are full we either entertain or we
entertain the people waiting so that
they don't leave all right I'm going to
go and brainwash them to vote for me
before they even come in the British
already invaded us once do you want it
to happen
again exactly so no matter what they say
to you they will try and brainwash you
don't listen to them right just remember
me I am one of you when they ask right
when they ask to be like if if one of
them tells you to come sit down be like
no I want
Joey most Australian C exactly all right
don't be a bunch of [__] and go with it
and go with the British people all right
come with me all right cool see you guys
in a
bit brainwash successful bone in or
boneless uh bone yes my good gentleman
is there anything more you want any any
water
anything you know sorry hug can I of
course you can here you go
man incredible oh thank you you love the
service thank you sorry no service for
you well we have to go I think with Joey
cuz the Australian charm like just felt
right at home I'm going to vote for
Connor is your first time first time in
dream yeah yeah yeah how you liking it
yeah it's been pretty good so far I'm
almost kind of sorry that this is your
first experience in dream oh why I came
just to see you guys oh really were you
expecting us to look like this though no
no not feel like you guys do wacky stuff
so it's too expected this is how we know
that's a true trash taste fan right
there me personally I'm probably done
both for Conor uh he's very funny come
on please please please please come on
man don't break my heart don't break my
heart come
on I'm about to leave this
Cafe there you go that was that was Al
for you both went for the chicken
nuggets set yes oh no I feel left out
now I can go and grab like a nugget from
someone oh my God can you does anyone
have a chicken nugget I can
have no good cuz you're all adults you
wouldn't get chicken nuggets we'll put
the kids on this table guys the chicken
nuggets guys go on this
table for
[Music]
Signature um I'm going to vote Joey
Conor he looks the best SC cuz
I'm going to go g cuz he actually talks
to us probably con all right well
normally you know you do like a little
bottle type of thing but uh this is a
this is this is an Australian staple
right here it's beautiful uh oh it's a
fish yeah yeah it's a fish it's a fish I
drew the Joker I see it that's good it's
good right going to ask for that yeah
right I went for Conor Joey I'm sorry I
went for Joey because why he's going to
stick together can't let down my boy
this is for me I need need I need some
hydration I love you too
man does anyone need anything any
napkins anything at all I have a napkin
you want a napkin all right this guy has
500 so I'm just going to take his feel
free to take the napkin wait these top
ones are are they used hey Master how
are you doing wait wait wait wait wait I
[__] are you guys doing over here I need
some advice on this and I know just the
person to ask for advice if I give you
my card uh-huh can you just get me a
bottle of water man sure thing beautiful
all right no worries of course I love
what are you doing just K his car what
the [__] I don't know if this is legal
or not but all right Che
mate so hot thank you I know here you go
go summer what a g i was very tossed up
between Connor and Joey like you know
Conor is Welsh I'm like part that so you
know Heritage in that but I did give
Joey my bank like my card and he did buy
me water so I gave it to Joey I have an
expert on how to act like an anime
character it's my wife
what should I say as a ma to my
customers who are right in front of me
right now oh
gosh this
is okay honey I hope you I hope you're
listening to me right now all
right producers have informed me that
people are not leaving hey guys uh if if
you're done with your food as they say
in Australia off um
I voted for gun cuz uh right at the end
con told me to off when I left so you
know he kind of doesn't deserve a vote
anymore okay okay mo
mo I didn't feel you didn't feel it I
hate this all right mo
[Applause]
mo I expect that vote oh my God I hate
my life uh apparently I've been just
taking Waters and not paying for them a
fan thankfully paid for my water for me
and I got to pay them back straight away
and someone gave me their shade
so I've now leveled up as a m I feel
like I am getting more equipment now so
I should be more leveled
up how you doing man how you doing you
look like a yuck as a side
character my character during a cut
scene all right I need I need some more
Source packets more sauce packets he
doesn't know the sauce packets are right
there all right here we
go oh
yo is that is that good five star is
that the highest yeah that's the highest
I think I'm going to vote for con cuz he
pulled me a five star on Fire Emblem
hero I'm sorry Joey sneak tokens sorry
uh sneak tokens in yeah then we can vote
for someone oh okay okay you know you
know what you know what
I that's that's that's a good strategy
right there that's a good strategy Alex
uh I don't know if this is part of the
rules but can I can I get some extra
tokens Can I can I sneak in some extra
tokens yeah I'll see what I can all
right all right all right all right boss
all right we have any tomato sauce ah if
you got like a box of them somewhere
supposed to charge all right that's a
big bag do you want me to hold it for
you come on you sure just won a couple
of stuff you just won what did you win
put in the keyboard you want to grab it
up oh you bought this no I wanted at to
spin the wheel thing wait where' you put
the tomato sauce it's back at the place
he's not giving it to me anymore yeah
cuz is he not no he's just like denying
giving it to me that's funny now is
there any Vibe you're looking for or any
kind of friendships you're hoping to
make today I trying to find love today
man you know you're trying to find love
find love yeah okay what do you envision
as your ideal partner uh um someone
dressed in a maze costume there's one
over there I can I can just I can just
bring you over and okay come on I'll
hook you up I'm bringing these guests
for you Joey do you want to sit down sir
what's up this guy wants to have
relations with you I'm just looking for
someone in a Maids costume and you fit
the you fit the profile pretty well
you've come to the right place so I was
uh looking to get an order in
for uh for some coins uh I don't know if
it came through or not uh they they
might have oh they might have oh
you know uh you know pleas you're doing
business I'm going to throw in a curve
ball I don't care if you vote for me I
just care that you don't vote for Connor
hey guys this guy likes sort out online
I got booed by everyone out there but
that's okay he still has my vote because
he needs it cuz the other two were just
bribing everyone so I got to help my boy
Conor out oh my God this is awesome
thank you so much this is amazing yeah
it's just drawing oh what's your
impression about everything that's going
on this so good voted for Joey because
personally he is my favorite but I love
all three of them all honesty um will
you dance uh a dance with me all right
you're going to have to show me and I'm
going to have to try and follow along
but let's do it let's do it like M them
all right it's very easy ready
yeah that's it is that it how' you rank
me out of 10 on that you did really well
you tried really hard than all right all
right be an idol you can be an idol I
can be an idol all right I just need I
just need a little bit more Idol
training and I think I'm there yeah
you're there you can be the next o I'm
going to vote for G because he did a ski
idle dance with me and he did really
well so I'm very proud what do you feel
about the voting the voting system at
the front there yeah um well all I'm
going to say is this uh you know the
British already invaded us once oh damn
do you want it to happen again oh he's
all right I'm going to turn this burger
into the most Kawai Burger you've ever
had in your life we're going to do it
together double power ready for
this can't believe that what what is
this [__] they're working together
trying to beat me I voted for Joey he
had a really convincing argument and his
a fellow Aussie I knew where my vote was
going all right anyway you didn't see
that you guys boneing gang or boneless
gang I don't professional chef yes I
believe there's Merit to both of them so
I do believe accessibility is is a
problem that we do sometimes have in
Industry yes and therefore I do have
think boneless is a good option for some
places but I also recognize that bone in
does actually add a little bit of flavor
to it and can be a more enjoyable
experience of using your hand s oh my
God oh my God wait wait before I freak
out too much I got to ask the other Chef
right here all right as your
professional opinion bone in or Bon less
probably bone in for proper chicken
unless it's nuggets oh my God can I
shake both your hands this this is uh
the first uh professional opinion we've
ever gotten on trash taste and we've
fact checked everything and it's it's
bone in baby it's bone in guys time is
up we are done and if you haven't voted
yet vote for me so far here are our
votes it looks pretty close if I'm being
honest no I think that g might have
cheated and then someone might have
fixed it yeah I think mine went down
quite significantly I wasn't playing
what wait wait there is no way I was
roaming around earlier just you know how
I am I like to keep track of the score
and G was really really low and then
suddenly it was just a lot of lot what
okay wait wait wait wait wait somehow in
the last 20 minutes uh Connor went from
being really really low no no no no I
was never low I was always in the what
is that Conor what is that this is
called swag ladies stop fighting all
right this is this is what the results
are only for day one but thankfully we
have a second day all right the second
day is where it all counts how's it feel
being a cheatah g how's it feel being a
cheatah Conor I'm not cheatting I don't
know what you're talking about Conor
it's uh it's Che some Something
Happening Here listen it's not cheating
if you're born this good how much copium
did you have to Huff when you uh set
that line there was a lot of cope
actually yeah all right well that's the
end of day one let's move on to day
two it is cold as today I'm so glad I'm
wearing these thigh highs though like
the these are keeping me warm right here
I got that nice pinch happening there as
well oh my nips are
hard it's so cold so I have a tail today
look at that look at that I don't know
if this is actually covering my ass I
really hope so cuz I don't want to be
flashing too many people welcome to the
trash taste made
Cafe we are now open for
service are you a real
Australian Australia isn't real that's
okay you got you got me there you got me
there are you going to get the kids
combo no just the chips thanks okay
smart are you going to get the kids
combo the veggie Burg wait what is this
I'm you you're me I'm you when you were
iron Mouse oh my God first okay first
channel your inner Kawaii all right
channel it why you laughing why why why
are you laughing why this is some
serious thing do not ruin the sanctity
of the maid Cafe please all right here
we go
ready what are you going to order today
grass-fed beef w what what is your
accent squash oh my God they caught me
off guard why are you here see you and
the boys oh I'm going to get the chicken
burger 100% manate okay nobody's getting
the kids combo this is good let's keep
it that way no kids combo hello what are
you ordering hello um probably the kids
meal cuz I'm
[Laughter]
broke now that you're here I have
something for you boys I want it from a
crane game while I was here here you
go I don't want that Joey do you want
this I want it from the crane game sure
I'll take it we got extra KO power right
here all right so we'll manifest the
power of meu as well I think you like
this I made this what the you made this
yeah embroidery it's an embroidery patch
is this for me yeah for you well thank
you so much for this and I hope you
enjoy the ma Cafe oh than you I will I
voted for Connor because monkey voted
for Connor all right here it comes you
ready Mo
Mo and Miku has ascended to the K Gods
thank you I'm going to give them some
service
filled with so much love all right
you're going to see how much love I'm
going to give them I've got your napkins
here and these napkins are filled with
extra love and extra Kawaii power who's
the uh the manager who's the manager you
don't want me to call the manager man
you don't want o Joey Joey yeah they
want to see the manager so what seems to
be theing problem I I'm aware there's a
bit of a competition going on yes yes
yes between you guys I'm not sure this
is uh part of the rule set what is what
is this this is uh what is this I was on
the table this is uh magic powers to
make us vote where did you get this
from he's lying he's lying Joe Joey Joey
come on you got to trust your employees
here you got to trust your employees
manager manager customer's always right
the customer is the god G I do not
accept this I'm going to take this away
from myself and uh I do not want to see
you doing this ever again okay otherwise
I will pull your tail out and shove it
down your throat you understand me all
right you know what
[__] guys vote I'm I'm going to another
table so do you guys accept bribes all
right so what I want you guys to do is
vote for me I voted for simply because
he brought me better than Joey did a lot
better give me two
actually all right all right are you
going to vote for me yes or no you going
to give me like you got to do the little
leg you I'm not doing any of that that's
their job I mean you can slip a the
table okay how about I see you slip all
your things in mine and then I slip of
you are fiver remember that I will bribe
you uh I'm M of a Connor and I'm
expecting a Fiverr which I was promised
but uh that's going to happen hey at
least you didn't call me gr that's
that's that's that's the good that's how
many grants have there been since you've
been here like three so far
unintentionally that's a low ball I
reckon I'm trying to do it so I wipe
everyone's mind so they make it seem
like Grant is like a madeup name so yeah
yeah I'm trying to get my name big
enough and get people to repeat it
enough that I'm like yeah Grant's the
real name here no Grant's
the you can do you can do it if you guys
want anything right now uh that I can
provide to you guys any service then uh
let me know napkins you want napkins in
10 seconds want napins now 10 seconds
all
right oh okay
you out
way I don't know if that was 10 second
it was 10 seconds in my
mind what has Joey been doing over here
I I got I got punished because I wasn't
fast enough to get the napkins you know
what I think I can give better service
than Joey napkin in 10 seconds clear the
way clear the way are you I'm
ready 1
[Music]
go he's not going to make
it no oh no he was slower than I was the
napkin box wasn't open God damn it
that's the problem I had yeah I'm gone
you took longer than 10 seconds have a
punishment as well already in
there now you kind of have to do the
same thing as Joey okay what do I need
to do kneel on the ground and
meow Joey I did it
Joey okay what is dignity anyway right
now more C damn it that that was with
the Kawaii in my
heart Joey did the best meow I made for
G cuz I just got fre napkins we for Joey
G came over it was horrible is there
anyone here who prefers bone and
Chicken all right hand out first I got
to show some love to my bro right here
we got to stick together you know yeah I
know right I've got some napkins for you
it is filled with extra love oh yeah but
what about the pizza crust man what
about the pizza crust I mean it's got to
be there right all right I'm taking this
P who else put the hand off for bone and
chicken no no no no there it is yes he
wants to arm wrestle for a point okay
okay ready all right 3 2 1
go all right I'll take mine thank you
yes thank you very much can I ask you
some questions yes what's the worst
thing about Australia the weather what
it gets hot and then it gets cold and it
gets really hot have have you have you
been to the UK
no what is the midest thing about
Australia the people you don't know
who's good or who's
bad guys this guy says Australians are
mid is this
[Applause]
true why do you have a peg what is uh is
there is there story behind this you can
infer what you will regarding that word
are you a taken man maybe yes I feel you
bro I feel you I feel you man gone
because you signed my Peg and you can
infer what this means I'm taken Man by
Conor Conor Conor Conor Conor Conor
Conor Joey Joey Joey uh I go Conor cuz I
just like the game Place full of
Charisma full of joy I voted for Joey
because he's obviously the most adorable
maid and also you know the English
already invaded us once we don't want it
to happen again I vote for Joey not
because I wanted him to win but because
I wanted Connor to lose ladies and
gentlemen may I have your attention we
are going to do a JoJo pose off oh it's
anything not JoJo but anything but
probably Jojo and you guys have to vote
for uh who has the best pose who's
everyone's favorite JoJo
character
[Laughter]
Jesus pose as Jesus Christ all right I'm
about to pose as Jesus Christ who is a
Canon JoJo character here we go
a thank
you your turn G all right so what
character can canonically beat Jesus
Goku Goku damn he's right and this is to
go even further
Beyond I just look like I'm [__]
[__] man all right guys I don't know
what to do here today but I okay how
about you shut the [__] up okay ready
chat why I saying chat what's wrong with
[Music]
[Applause]
me that's a free flash guys all right
remember that if you guys liked Joey's
post give me a give me a che give me a
screen on 3 2
1 all right now let's hear it for Conor
on 3 2 1 w
W and finally for G 3 2
1 of course it's all the dudes that love
Goku po Joy Conor took the L what the
Yeah Conor took the L on that one all
right should we do one more Jojo pose
then all right best Jojo pose Joey best
Joo pose okay here we go I think my
favorite might be the God himself deal
here we
[Music]
go oh I feel powerful after that I can
actually only do one I think JoJo po so
I hope you guys like
[Music]
it he practices every night the finale
can we get out 3 2 1 for
Joey o that sound a mean mix and
probably the winner 3 to up for
guard you were right Goku can beat Jesus
thank you so much
got no one oh thank you than guys come
on come on guys one L one L let's go
let's go let's get those V in come on
let's pump those numbers these are rocky
numbers come on guys we have the results
they are in that was a quick counting
Jesus all right the results are in boys
for the ma Cafe starting from the winner
so the winner of the trash taste made
Cafe the best made with 86
tokens is
G yes
oh oh joh did cheat Yesterday by he
cheat yesterday he did yeah I don't know
what you're talking about the difference
in votes so it's only by five
tokens unfortunately with 78
tokens
Joey is the trashiest
maze I think you know cuz you can cheat
in a trash taste special but you got to
not get caught I think that maybe Gant
should have to you know do the
punishment with you cuz he also cheated
he did also cheat what do you guys
reckon what do you guys reckon
he you know what for my bro I'll do it
man I'll do it this is why he's my bro
I'll do it all right now that I was
crowned as the winner of the maid Cafe
experience it was time for a trash tast
special punishment as we all know
friends cheaters never prosper and let's
just say Joey and G might have a little
bit of a chilling experience all right
we're finally back in Japan and I got to
say it feels good to be a winner you
know who's not a winner the guys that's
why they're dressed like this in the
streets of akih Habra so uh gentlemen
why don't you go have a little walk
around I think I would prefer to have
done this in Australia cuz in Australia
be like oh it's just not a Aussie is it
here I can see the silent judgment it is
so busy 7° right now I am freezing my
this jacket is fantastic anyway boys
come on get going enjoy
all right let's go then off we go let's
walk the streets the first rule let's
not run into any fans while that would
be great on the street let's not do that
I've never been so heavily judged in my
life like my parents judged me when I
became a YouTuber this is not even close
I feel like this has been a losing
Dignity speedrun of a
video I'm one of you guys as I just
waved at the maid the maid was just like
competition I see
he's hot you know what I discovered
today Joey what rock bottom has a
Sellar here guys atten cute
M say I'm going to I'm going to kill
this I'm going to kill I am going to
kill this man look at them look at them
they love it they love this attention
wow cute mides guys I love the cute
Maids Guys somebody said you were Kawaii
behind me we're on the main strip of
aaba right now all right get some get
some customers go get some customers
boys I can't believe I [__] cheated in
the game and I still ended up losing you
know what Joey I hope you're happy that
I'm doing this with my bro I'm really
I'm really happy I couldn't have done
this by myself this is kind of weird so
let's not
do my Gant looks like a man in a midlife
crisis that girl just gave me the
biggest side eye I've ever seen she she
walked faster she was like oh there's a
m right there guys what about the other
maid you just went walk I ped hello nice
thank you thank you thank you thank
you oh God they're filming us people
people are now filming us hi
hello oh no why are there so many people
you recognize us this is not good yeah
you want a photo of course of course
we're let's get a photo let's get one of
the first worst photos you've ever
taken my so
tall I've never had so many Japanese
people like approaching me talking that
gu F me got another fan all
right you know uh I think uh this is the
last time I'm going to go to aabra again
in my life this um this is the last time
I'm going to be here for a while that's
for sure everyone's staring at them I
don't think my eyes could take
this all right nice phone all right I
think you boys have suffered enough all
right I'm I'm pleased mainly because I
don't want to walk around with you guys
any longer and I think this really was a
lesson in why I was the best made all
along yeah sure totally that's why I
didn't walk around in the street like a
hooker uh ma excuse you it's okay it's
okay next next special we'll bring it
back whatever that's going to be and
we're going to make the punishment even
harsher next time oh yeah totally Conor
has to lose a toe oh Jesus all right so
Connor you got the dub but really really
did you get the dub of course I did of
course I did I don't know feel like he
was the best he was the best there was
some foul play going on there this this
is annoying that whenever I get a win it
has to be oh I don't know and when you
guys would I'm very gracious in defeat
all right [__] not extremely gracious
in defeat this is unfair I'm just saying
I won fair and square you guys lost and
on the next special I'll win again and
then I'll win again and I'll win again I
can't believe I had to do what I just
did uh and I dragged g into it which was
great okay I did it for I did it for my
bro I'm sure you would have done the
same for me Joey absolutely and you and
you do right Conor uh nope nope would
not he would I would not uh but if you
did enjoy this special please go and
support us on patreon as that's how we
fund making these specials and bigger
projects uh and yeah check it out if you
also go over to our patreon as well then
you'll actually be able to get access to
behind the scenes of the special as well
because we obviously couldn't include
everything uh in the special so if you'd
like to check out extra scenes as well
as support future specials and the show
itself then head on over to patreon.com
trast yeah and here's what we got coming
up next guys where do we get started I
you can change in Clos like this B and
put here what do I do if my feet don't
work yeah put
that visual visualizing training uh did
not pay off so guys hope you enjoyed
this episode of trash taste outside
we'll see you on our next episode
[Music]
bye